presque toute l'Ukraine est complètement
plongée dans le noir des coupures
d'urgence ont été mises en place afin
que certains endroits essentiels comme
les hôpitaux par exemple puissent
continuer de fonctionner mais les
frappes russes continuent et elles vise
toujours aussi intensément les
infrastructures énergétiques à Odessa où
nous nous trouvons il n'y a
effectivement plus de lumière mais c'est
le cas aussi pour d'autres grandes
villes comme vivent des pros soumis
l'électricité est complètement à l'arrêt
même jusqu'en Moldavie voisine des
coupures massives ont eu lieu et bien
sûr dans la capitale Kiev la situation
est la même l'accès à l'eau aussi a été
coupée le maire de la ville a exhorté
les habitants à rester dans leurs abris
on compte au moins trois morts et s'y
blessés sur place Carson aussi un peu
plus tôt dans la journée un adolescent
de 13 ans a succombé à ses blessures
tandis que ce matin une maternité était
touchée par les bombardements russes à
villeignansk près de zapporija un
nouveau-né il a perdu la vie
et puis le